تنقل محمد المصاب بمرض فشل الكلوي بعد
مغادرته الخرطوم هربا من الحرب من مدينه
الى اخرى بحثا عن مركز غسل كولا استقر به
الحال في بورسودان حيث المركز الوحيد لغسل
الكلى في المدينه انتظر الفرصه للغسل بس
يمكن اليها سته يوم ما غسلته
فالحمد لله على كل حال ده كله بسبب الحرب
مراكز غسل الكلى في ولايات السودان تكتظ
بالمرضى القادمين من الخرطوم فرص علاجهم
تتظاهل كل ما زادت اعدادهم لكن شده مرض
بعضهم لا تحتمل التاخير
الضغط على هذا المركز يفوق طاقته
الاستيعابيه مع حاجه كل مريض لغسل كليته
مرتين اسبوعيا امكانيات المركز في الاساس
كانت شحيحه قبل الحرب نعاني من نقص في
المستهلكات وشارفنا على التوقف اذا خلال
اسبوع اسبوعين نحن ما وصلتنا المستهلكات
المركز مواجهه تماما
مركز علاج الاورام السرطانيه وجه اخر من
معاناه المصابين بالامراض المزمنه في
البلاد يخضع نحو ثلاثه الاف مريض بالسرطان
هنا للعلاج بعضهم قدم من الخرطوم اوقفت
الحرب ما كان يحصل عليه المركز من امدادات
طبيه حكوميه وتخشى طواقمه ان يصبح غير
قادر على مواصله تقديم خدماته عايزين اسرع
انذاب من الدواء
بالاضافه
للاحتياجات الاخرى لتسيير المركز من
محاليل وريديه يعني غير الادويه الخاصه
بالسرطان
وصلت الى البلاد مساعدات طبيه وزعت على
ولايات عده لكن معظمها لا يستهدف مراكز
علاج الامراض المزمنه بدرجه رئيسيه فمن
طالب المنظمات اللي هي تدعم الصحه زي
المنظمه الصحه العالميه واليونسيف وسيفه
وجلدرين كل هذا المنظمات هي بتدعم معانا
في احتياجاتنا بالنسبه للامراض المزمنه
وبقيه الامراض ما وصل من مساعدات طبيه لا
يكفي قياسا بالقدرات المحدوده بالمستشفيات
والمراكز الطبيه مع استمرار النزوح من
الخرطوم واصبح الوضع الصحي ينذر بمخاطر
حقيقيه تهدد حياه الاف المرضى في البلاد
اكثر القطاعات الخدميه تاثرا بالحرب في
السودان هو القطاع الصحي فانهيار كثيرا من
الخدمات الطبيه في شكل ضغطا كبيرا على
مستشفيات الولايات وهو ما قد يجعلها غير
قادره على الصمود طويلا لتقديم خدماتها
اذا لم تصلها مساعدات عاجله حمدي البكاري
الجزيره بورسودان